>> PREVIOUSLY...
ON AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> SHOULD I BE INNOCENT
OR MORE SEXY?
>> NATASHA, THE RUSSIAN BEAUTY,
GOT LOST IN TRANSLATION.
>> A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL
WITH THAT LEG
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE SITTING ON THE TOILET.
>> DESPITE HER BEST EFFORTS,
RENEE COULDN'T CONTROL
HER TEMPER.
>> (crying) I CANNOT STAND
THESE GIRLS, JASON.
>> AT JUDGING,
DIONNE'S PERSONAL STYLE
LACKED AN EDGE.
YOU STILL LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE AUDITIONING
FOR "TOP MODEL," NOT LIKE--
NOT LIKE THIS IS THE FIFTH WEEK.
>> I DO?!
>> NO.
BUT IT WAS
FELICIA'S LIFELESS PHOTO...
DIONNE.
THAT SEALED HER FATE.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪♪
(phone rings)
>> Hello?
>> DO YOU MISS ME?
>> Of course I miss you.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER ME?
>> Of course I remember you.
>> EVERYTHING?
>> Everything.
Hey, uh, you wanna
talk to little Buggy-Bug?
>> (laughs)
I'M GONNA HEAR MY BABY
FIRST TIME IN THREE WEEKS.
IT'S... IT'S REAL IMPORTANT.
I FEEL LIKE, BEING A MODEL,
YOU WILL BE AWAY
FROM YOUR FAMILY.
MOST OF THE TIME,
YOU HAVE TO WORK.
HEY, LITTLE BABY.
HONEY, IT'S MAMA TALKING.
>> (speaking indistinctly)
>> (baby cooing)
>> OH, MY GOD! BABY!
I'M REALLY SAD.
I'M NOT BONDING
WITH ANYBODY IN THE HOUSE.
WE WOULD NEVER BE FRIENDS
WITH EACH OTHER
BECAUSE WE'RE SO DIFFERENT.
>> DO YOU EVER REALIZE THE FACT
THAT WHEN NATASHA GOT MARRIED,
SHE WAS ONLY 18
AND HER HUSBAND WAS 40,
AND SHE COULDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH?
>> DAMN.
>> DON'T YOU THINK
THAT'S KIND OF WEIRD?
>> MM-HMM.
>> I NEED YOU, STUART. (growls)
>> (laughs)
>> (purrs and growls)
MEOW.
>> THINK SHE WAS LIKE
A MAIL-ORDER BRIDE?
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT.
>> LIKE, FOR HER VISA?
IT'S CREEPY.
>> IT IS. GROSS!
>> WOULD YOU BE GENTLE TO ME?
>> Of course.
>> MMM.
(presses telephone button)
>> SORRY.
♪♪♪
>> MM-HMM.
>> I SHOULD GET ON THAT, TOO.
I DEFINITELY THINK
THAT HAVING DIANA AROUND,
IT--IT'S EASIER.
SHE AND I ARE
THE TWO PLUS-SIZED MODELS,
AND I THINK IT'S JUST EASIER
HAVING SOMEBODY THERE
WHO CAN RELATE TO YOU.
'CAUSE I THINK YOU GET
A DISTORTED PERCEPTION
OF REALITY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LIVE WITH
A WHOLE BUNCH OF GIRLS
WHO ARE 5'10"
AND ONLY WEIGH 125 POUNDS.
>> I'M GONNA HAVE TO START
STEALING FOOD.
>> (laughs)
>> TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL!
"LOOKING YOUR WORST
CAN BE THE BEST THING
THAT EVER HAPPENED TO YOU.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OH, I WIN THIS ONE.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
>> HI, LADIES. HOW ARE YOU?
>> HI.
>> WELCOME.
MY NAME IS CATHY GOULD.
I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT.
>> IT'S SO AMAZING
MEETING A PERSON
THAT'S SO HIGH UP
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND SHE COULD BE THE ONE,
BASICALLY, HOLDING OUR CAREER
IN HER HANDS.
>> UH, WITH ME TODAY
IS AN ELITE MODEL--
CLAUDIA MASON.
♪♪♪
>>CLAUDIA HAS GRACED
ALL THE MAJOR FASHION MAGAZINES,
AND HAS WALKED THE RUNWAYS
FOR THE TOP DESIGNERS
IN PARIS, MILAN AND NEW YORK.
>> AND, YOU KNOW,
CATHY AND I ARE HERE BECAUSE
IT IS SO IMPORTANT FOR A MODEL
TO KNOW HOW TO DRESS.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING WITH YOU TODAY.
>> AT LAST PANEL,
TYRA AND THE JUDGES
DID NOT LIKE MY OUTFIT.
THEY CHEWED MY ASS OUT.
>> THAT TANK TOP IS...
>> TOO MUCH.
>> NOT GOOD.
THE LACE, THE TWINKLES,
THE COLOR.
>> LOOKS KIND OF LIKE
A MALL LOOK WITH THOSE JEANS.
>> I WAS SHOCKED AS HELL!
SO I'M JUST GONNA TRY TO JUST
LISTEN AND PAY ATTENTION TODAY.
>> SO CATHY AND I
HAVE PULLED OUT SOME EXAMPLES
FOR YOU GUYS TO SHOWCASE.
JUST GO AND--AND TRY THEM ON
AND THEN COME RIGHT BACK.
>> (laughs)
>> OKAY, TELL US WHAT YOU THINK.
>> I LIKE THIS OUTFIT VERY MUCH.
I ALWAYS--YOU SHOULD WEAR
THE SKINNY JEANS, TIGHT SHIRTS,
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE
YOUR BODY.
>> AND I LOVE THE ACCESSORIES--
THE EARRINGS AND THE NECKLACE.
>> I THINK MY OUTFIT'S
FUN, YOUNG AND HIP.
IT LOOKS LIKE I CAN
WEAR IT OUT FOR A CASUAL NIGHT
OR I CAN GO FOR LUNCH.
>> ACTUALLY, LADIES,
THE OUTFITS
THAT WE PICKED FOR YOU
ARE EXAMPLES
OF HOW NOT TO DRESS.
(record needle scratches)
>> (laughs)
>> I WAS LIKE, OH, SNAP!
I WAS LIKE,
WE WERE LOOKING KIND OF
JACKED UP AND BUSTED HERE.
>> SO WE ARE GONNA TELL YOU WHY,
AND WE SHALL START WITH DIANA.
THIS TOP IS LIKE
A POTATO SACK ON YOU.
IT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING.
>> TAKE THAT TOP OFF
AND THROW IT AWAY.
>> WHOO! BYE-BYE!
>> GREAT. FANTASTIC.
>> OKAY.
>> NATASHA...
YOU HAVE A GREAT THIN FRAME.
SO THEN A THIN TOP
WITH A THIN BOTTOM--
IT'S--IT'S JUST TOO MUCH.
>> IT LOOKS MORE LIKE
YOU'RE WALKING THE STREETS
INSTEAD OF WALKING THE RUNWAY.
>> BUT I MAKE IT WORK.
ALL THE GIRLS SAY
THEY LIKE THEIR OUTFIT
JUST BECAUSE, BEING A MODEL,
YOU SHOULD ALWAYS LIKE
THE CLOTHING THEY PUT ON YOU.
>> NATASHA FRUSTRATES ME.
IF SOMEBODY'S TRYING
TO GIVE YOU A LESSON,
YOU SHOULD JUST LISTEN
AND TAKE THAT LESSON
AND APPLY IT TO YOURSELF.
>> OKAY, SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
WORK SOME MAGIC.
SO, NATASHA,
TAKE OFF YOUR GRAY LEGGINGS.
GIVE THEM TO RENEE.
RENEE, TAKE OFF
THE BLUE BUBBLE SKIRT.
GIVE IT TO NATASHA.
>> JAEL AND BRITTANY,
YOU'RE GONNA SWITCH TOPS.
JASLENE, THOSE PANTS--
THROW THEM AWAY.
WHITNEY, THE ACCESSORIES
AROUND YOUR NECK
IS WAY TOO HEAVY.
IT MAKES YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU HAVE A SHORT NECK.
>> GIVE IT TO DIANA, PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
SARAH, TAKE OFF THOSE PANTS
AND GIVE THEM TO MISS JASLENE.
RENEE, PLEASETAKE OFF
THOSE PINK STILETTOS.
AND, NATASHA,
TAKE OFF THOSE BLACK PUMPS.
GIVE THEM TO RENEE.
>> NOW YOU HAVE AN IDEA
OF WHAT WORKS.
>> YEP.
>> THE OUTFITS-- MAYBE NOT
PERFECT-PERFECT,
BUT IT'S--IT'S CLOSE.
>> I DID LEARN SOMETHING TODAY--
SIMPLE, THAT'S ALL YOU NEED.
>> BYE, GUYS. HAVE A GREAT DAY.
>> BYE.
♪♪♪
>> DO YOU HONESTLY THINK
THAT THERE'S EVER GONNA BE
A PLUS-SIZED MODEL
ON THE COVER OF "VOGUE"?
I JUST THINK THAT THAT'S NEVER
ACTUALLY GONNA HAPPEN.
LIKE, NO MATTER HOW MUCH
I WANT IT TO HAPPEN,
I DON'T THINK THAT
IT'S GOING TO.
>> RENEE HONESTLY SAYS
A LOT OF THINGS
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I COULD BE ON THE COVER
OF "VOGUE" MAGAZINE
WEARING A SIZE 8 TO 10
AND LOOK DARN GOOD
WHILE DOING IT.
I'LL SHOW YOU
I COULD BE A MODEL,
AND I WILL SHOW YOU
THAT I'M A MODEL.
>> WAITIN' TO SEE IT.
>> IT'S COMING.
>> RENEE, SHUT THE HECK UP.
GET OUT OF MY FACE.
♪♪♪
>> I WEAR A 8.
EXCUSE ME...
>> REGARDLESS, CAN YOU BELIEVE
SHE SAID SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
AND SHE DIDN'T THINK IT WAS...
>> SHE'S TRYING TO SAY
THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY MODELS.
THAT'S WHAT SHE WAS
TRYING TO DO.
>> RENEE--
SHE'S, LIKE, THE BITCH.
YOU JUST DON'T WANNA
LISTEN TO HER ANYMORE.
I'M MAD.
(laughs evilly) OH, MY GOD.
♪♪♪
>> WE ARRIVE
AT THIS SEARS WAREHOUSE,
AND THERE ARE TWO MANNEQUINS.
AND I'M GOING, THOSE ARE REALLY
REALISTIC-LOOKING MANNEQUINS.
>> HI, GIRLS.
MY NAME IS LAWRENCE ZARIAN,
AND THIS IS...
>> (laughing)
>> HI, I'M GREGORY. WELCOME.
>> THIS IS MY IDENTICAL TWIN
BROTHER GREGORY.
>> HI THERE.
>> AND WE HAVE BOTH
BEEN FORTUNATE
TO WORK IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY
FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
>> LADIES, WE HEARD
THAT YOU LEARNED
HOW TO DRESS YOURSELVES.
YOU LEARNED ABOUT COMBINATIONS.
YOU LEARNED ABOUT WHAT WORKS,
WHAT DOESN'T WORK.
>> DID YOU LISTEN?
>> YES!
>> SO TODAY,
WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO
IS CREATE SOME FASHIONABLE LOOKS
FOR AN IN-STORE DISPLAY.
>> LIKE WE'VE DONE HERE.
WE ARE KNOWN AS ZARIAN SQUARED.
>> NOW WE'RE GONNA
SPLIT YOU UP INTO THREE GROUPS.
YOU THREE OVER HERE,
YOU'RE GROUP ONE.
>> GROUP TWO.
>> AND THEN YOU THREE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE,
YOU'RE GROUP THREE.
>> HE TOLD ME THAT
MY GROUP MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO BE
SARAH AND RENEE.
AND I WAS LIKE...
(groans) SARAH AND RENEE.
I DON'T REALLY TALK TO SARAH
THAT MUCH, OR RENEE,
SO I WASN'T TOO THRILLED
ABOUT IT.
>> EACH TEAM HAS
TWO RACKS OF CLOTHING--
YOU'RE USING THE HOTTEST TRENDS
FROM SEARS--
AND EVERYTHING YOU COULD WANT
IN ACCESSORIES.
>> YOU WILL BE EVALUATED
INDEPENDENTLY AND AS A GROUP,
SO IT'S NOT JUST YOU
BY YOURSELF.
IT'S LOOKS THAT LOOK AMAZING
TOGETHER,
FROM OUR FRIENDS AT SEARS.
>> I'M GONNA BE WITH
WHITNEY AND JAEL.
WE ARE SO DIFFERENT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE'RE GONNA DO THIS.
(laughs)
>> YOU HAVE 20 MINUTES
TO COMPLETE THIS CHALLENGE.
BY THE TIME 20 MINUTES ARE UP,
YOU HAVE TO BE IN YOUR POSE
AND ON THE PLATFORM,
OR YOU WILL BE DISQUALIFIED.
>> DISQUALIFIED.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> YEAH!
>> ON YOUR MARK...
>> GET SET...
>> GO!
♪♪♪
>> YES!
>> DON'T WEAR THIS.
IT DOESN'T GO.
>> BUT THAT'S MY STYLE.
>> NO, BUT THIS IS
A GROUP THING, BABY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THIS?
>> WE NEED A SKIRT!
WE NEED A SKIRT.
>> HERE, PANTS.
I'VE WORKED IN RETAIL BEFORE.
SINCE I HAVE EXPERIENCE,
I WAS LIKE, OKAY, I'M JUST GONNA
PICK OUT OUR OUTFITS.
WE GOT BLACK SHOES?
BUT SARAH GOES
AND GETS ALL THIS CRAZY STUFF,
AND I'M LIKE,
OKAY, ALL THIS STUFF
IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
>> THIS IS GOLD,
SO THE JEWELRY ISN'T GONNA WORK.
I'M GONNA GO GRAB SOMETHING
TO SWITCH.
>> YES, YOU NEED THE PEARLS.
THE PEARLS.
NEVER HAVE I WON A CHALLENGE,
AND I'M DYING INSIDE
'CAUSE I WANNA WIN A CHALLENGE
SO BAD.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M FOCUSED ON.
>> LADIES,
YOU HAVE FIVE MORE MINUTES
FOR THE COMPETITION.
YOU SHOULD BE
WRAPPING IT UP NOW.
>> WHAT'S MY OUTFIT?
WHERE'S MY OUTFIT?
WHICH ONE'S MINE?
>> OKAY, THIS BRACELET'S
PERFECT FOR ME.
>> WHICH ONE'S MY OUTFIT, GUYS?
THIS ONE?
>> YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS.
>> OKAY, GET UP HERE.
>> COME ON, COME ON!
WHITNEY, WHITNEY!
>> FIVE, FOUR...
>> GET UP HERE.
>> THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> KEEP YOUR POSES.
>> SHH! SHUSH.
>> OKAY, SO HERE WE HAVE
THE "SPRING MONARCHS."
>> AS A GROUP,
IT'S A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON.
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO FASHION,
I DO LIKE THAT
EACH GIRL CHOSE COLORS
THAT COMPLEMENTED YOUR SKIN TONE
AND YOUR HAIR COLORING.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
"TRES FLORES"--
THREE FLOWERS.
THE COLORS COMPLEMENT
YOUR LOOKS,
BUT YOU DON'T ALL COMPLEMENT
EACH OTHER.
FINALLY, WE HAVE--
HOLD ON, LET ME LOOK.
WHO SPELLED THAT?
>> WHEN YOU NAME SOMETHING,
YOU CAN SPELL IT AS WRONG
OR AS RIGHT AS YOU WANT.
>> YEAH.
>> NATASHA IS
THE USED CAR SALESMAN
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THEY SPELLED "APHRODITE" WRONG,
AND SHE'S LIKE, "MNH-MNH-MNH,
YOU CAN SPELL THE--THE WORD
AS DIFFERENT AS YOU WANT."
>> I REALLY LIKE THE DISPLAY.
>> IT'S SIMPLE.
I THINK IT'S CLEAN.
MY EYE ISN'T GOING
FROM PIECE TO PIECE.
IT'S LOOKING AT
THE ENTIRE PICTURE,
AND THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOW IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE IN THIS BUSINESS,
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN.
WE WOULD HAVE PICKED
GROUP NUMBER THREE,
"APHRODITY'S BOX."
THIS WAS OUR FAVORITE LOOK.
>> (mouths word)
>> BUT WE TOLD YOU
THAT YOU HAD TO BE
ON YOUR SPACES.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT,
YOU'RE DISQUALIFIED.
AND, WHITNEY...
YOU WOULD'VE WON.
>> YOU WOULD'VE BEEN THE WINNER
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS.
>> I JUST FEEL A HUGE BLOW.
WE HAD THAT ONE IN THE BAG,
AND I WON
THE INDIVIDUAL CHALLENGE,
AND, UM, I BASICALLY
JUST GAVE THAT ONE AWAY.
>> THE NEXT TEAM
THAT WE CHOSE WAS
THE SPRING MONARCHS.
>> YAY!
>> IT GOES TO SPRING MONARCHS.
>> WE DECIDED
THERE IS ONE PERSON, THOUGH,
THAT CREATED A LOOK
THAT REALLY COMPLEMENTED
THEIR BODY TYPE,
THEIR SKIN COLORING
AND THEIR FIGURE PERFECTLY.
SARAH, CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
>> I'M LIKE, OKAY...
HOW THE HELL
DID SARAH JUST WIN?
I WAS LIKE, BUT I DRESSED HER,
SO I THINK I SHOULD BE GETTING
A LITTLE RECOGNITION OVER HERE.
>> DAMN!
>> WE LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU CHOSE A TOP
WITH A SCOOP NECK,
AND YOU LISTENED
WHEN IT CAME TO THE ACCESSORIES.
>> I GOT THE JEWELRY.
I PICKED OUT THE SHIRT.
DIONNE PICKED OUT THE PANTS.
AND WE SAID, "SARAH,
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE WEARING."
SO SHE DIDN'T DO
ANY OF THE WORK.
>> AND I SAW THE BLUE,
AND I WAS LIKE, I LOVE THE BLUE,
BECAUSE BLUE JUST COMPLEMENTS
MY HAIR COLOR AND EVERYTHING.
I WON MY FIRST CHALLENGE.
IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
I WAS KIND OF SHOCKED
THAT I WON,
BUT I'M REALLY EXCITED. (laughs)
>> HERE'S THE DEAL, SARAH--
THE NEXT TIME
YOU DO A PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU'LL GET TO DO IT TWICE.
SO YOU GET TO DO
THE PHOTO SHOOT,
THEN YOU GO AND SIT WITH JAY
AND GO THROUGH
ALL THE SHOTS YOU TOOK.
HE'LL TELL YOU WHAT WORKS,
HE'LL TELL YOU
WHAT DOESN'T WORK,
AND THEN YOU GET TO DO IT AGAIN.
>> YAY!
>> IT'S BEEN OUR PLEASURE TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US
PLAY WITH YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> IT MAKES ME SICK
TO MY STOMACH THAT I COULD'VE
WON THIS CHALLENGE AND I DIDN'T.
NATASHA TOLD ME
TO GET ON THE PLATFORM,
AND SHE'S ACTUALLY TELLING ME
A VALUABLE PIECE OF INFORMATION,
BUT, UM, SOMETIMES I DO
TUNE NATASHA OUT
'CAUSE SHE HAS A TENDENCY
TO TALK A LOT.
(laughs)
>> I-I-I DID.
I-I REMEMBER I SAID THAT
WE HAVE TO BE ON THE PLATFORM.
I THINK THAT WHITNEY HEARD ME,
BUT SHE DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION.
NOBODY WOULD LISTEN TO ME.
THEY WOULD NOT EVEN
GIVE ME A CHANCE TO SPEAK UP.
>> MM-HMM. IT IS SUSPECT.
>> ONLY MEAN GIRLS
ARE STAYING IN THE HOUSE,
AND IT'S JUST LIKE NO RESPECT.
AND THAT'S NOT MAKING ME HAPPY.
(crying) WHY ARE THEY
PICKING ON ME NOW?
>> I thought you were
getting along with the girls.
>> WELL, YEAH,
I THOUGHT SO, TOO.
>> Don't get upset.
>> DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND?
>> Well, I understand what--
>> MAYBE I DIDN'T
EXPLAIN IT RIGHT,
OR YOU JUST DON'T
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> No, baby, I--I'm--
I understand what you're saying.
You gotta be tough now.
>> (sobbing) BUT IF--
♪♪♪
>> ♪ TYRA MAIL ♪
>> OPEN IT.
>> OPEN IT UP.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT
WE BE DOING TOMORROW, YO.
>> "DUDE!
WHERE'S MY LIPSTICK?
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I WONDER IF THERE'S
GONNA BE BOYS.
>> OH, MY!
>> (screaming and laughing)
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> MM-HMM.
>> THIS WAS MY INSPIRATION.
TYRA AND JAY ASKED ME
TO BUY A LOT OF MAGAZINES
AND JUST STUDY MY POSING,
STUDY MY FACIAL EXPRESSIONS,
AND--WHICH I'M DOING RIGHT NOW,
AND I THINK I'M GETTING
REAL BETTER AT IT.
I THINK THAT IT WILL HELP ME
TO DO BETTER
AT THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> HI!
>> WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN LEARNING
THIS WEEK?
YOU'VE BEEN LEARNING ABOUT
THE CLOTHES ON YOUR BACK
AND WHAT TO WEAR.
SO TODAY, YOU GIRLS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO STYLE YOURSELVES
IN A VERY SLEEK PHOTO SHOOT.
SO GO!
>> (screams)
♪♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT, LET ME GUESS...
THIS IS WHAT
THE HOUSE LOOKS LIKE.
>> IT'S NOT THAT BAD.
>> NO.
>> IT'S NOT THAT BAD?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> WELL, I COULD TELL YOU
WHAT'S BAD, THOUGH... THIS.
THIS IS A MESS.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU GIRLS
REALLY NEED SOME HELP
IN THE STYLE DEPARTMENT.
MAYBE SOME ACCESSORIES
WILL DO THE TRICK.
WE'VE GOT SOME MALE MODELS HERE.
♪♪♪
>> (laughing)
>> I KNEW IT!
>> AND I THINK
A REAL STYLE CHALLENGE WOULD BE
IF YOU WEAR THE GUYS' CLOTHES,
AND I THINK THESE GUYS
CAN WEAR THE GIRLS' CLOTHES.
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> YEAH!
>> BUT I NEED TO WARN YOU.
THEY ALREADY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY'RE DRAG QUEENS.
>> OH, MY GOD! ARE YOU FOR REAL?
I'LL BE ALL MAN TODAY.
>> THE ROOM IS COMPLETE MAYHEM.
I LOOK OVER, AND I SEE A DUDE,
AND I LOOK A LITTLE CLOSER,
AND IT'S NATASHA.
AND I LOOK TO MY LEFT,
AND I SEE THIS WOMAN,
AND IT'S ACTUALLY A DUDE.
IT WAS JUST... CONFUSING.
>> I'M A HOT DUDE.
>> BLAZER, THESE ARE YOUR PANTS.
>> OH, THAT'S SO COOL.
I GET TO BE A FRAT BOY!
>> YES.
>> I'M A--I'M A COLLEGIATE.
THAT'S THE TITLE
OF MY CHARACTER, AND I'M, LIKE,
A COLLEGE FRAT BOY.
I GO TO SCHOOL IN THAT. LIKE--
>> WHAT--WHAT SCHOOL
DO YOU GO TO?
>> DARTMOUTH.
>> OH, MY GOD! I HAD NO IDEA.
>> (laughs) YEAH.
>> "NAUTICAL" MEANS THAT
YOU'RE, LIKE, ON THE BOAT.
YOU KNOW, THOSE PREPPY PEOPLE
THAT ARE ON YACHTS.
>> A YACHT? A YACHT?
>> YES. YEAH.
>> I'M THE NAUTICAL BOY.
MY DATE'S GETTING HER HAIR DID.
LOOK AT THE WAY YOU'RE SITTING.
CROSS THOSE LEGS.
I'M JUST BASICALLY
A MAN IN HIS YACHT,
ENJOYING THE BEAUTY OF NATURE.
>> THIS IS RICHARD,
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER FOR TODAY.
>> I GOTTA FART...
(deep voice) LIKE A MAN.
>> (laughs)
WORK IT. THERE YOU GO.
JASLENE COMMANDED THAT SET.
>> BUT YOU WANNA PUT YOUR...
>> SHE WAS DIRECTING.
SHE'S STEPPING UP HER GAME.
JASLENE KNOWS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
IT WAS VERY--
VERY SOPHISTICATED-LOOKING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> I SHOOT DEERS.
>> (laughs)
>> I AM ASSIGNED THE CHARACTER
OF AN OUTDOORSY PERSON.
>> (laughing)
>> YEAH!
>> AND IT WAS A LITTLE HARD
TO PLAY SORT OF A TOUGH GUY LOOK
WHEN DESTINY IS CRACKING ME UP,
AND I'M SITTING THERE GOING,
"DON'T LAUGH. DON'T LAUGH.
JUST LOOK STERN."
>> (laughing)
BRITT AIN'T EVEN GON' FLINCH.
SHE'S NOT PLAYIN' TODAY.
NOT ONLY WERE THEY GOOD SHOTS...
>> HELL, YEAH!
>> IT WAS ENTERTAINING AS HELL.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
ROCK STAR, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I AM ASSIGNED GLAM ROCK.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
A ROCK STAR.
>> BUT IF YOU JUST
CLENCH DOWN ON YOUR JAW...
THERE YOU GO.
NOW YOU'RE INSTANTLY GONNA
GET THAT, AND IT'S GONNA
LOOK MORE MASCULINE
WITHOUT THAT... LOOK.
LOVE THE ENERGY,
LOVE THE ATTITUDE.
OH, I LIKE THAT, RENEE.
I LOVE THE VARIETY.
THERE YA GO!
>> I GOT POSITIVE FEEDBACK
FROM JAY.
HOPEFULLY,
I'LL GET CALLED FIRST AGAIN.
>> THAT'S THE SHOT!
>> HEY! (laughs)
>> YOU'RE CRAZY, HONEY.
>> I'M ASSIGNED
THE--THE BOHEMIAN MAN.
>> OKAY, JAEL,
THIS IS LOTS OF FUN.
>> MY PHOTO SHOOT WAS AMAZING.
WHEN I ALLOW MY SOUL
TO BE CAPTURED IN A PHOTOGRAPH,
I'M ACTUALLY, LIKE,
OPENING MYSELF INSIDE OUT.
>> (laughs)
YOU ARE A CUCKOO-CRAZY
COCOA PUFF.
>> ALL RIGHT. (laughs)
>> IS THAT MY WIFE?
>> WE'RE NOT MARRIED.
>> YOU'RE NOT MARRIED.
YEAH, WE'RE TOO BUSY
TO BE MARRIED.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> SO YOU GUYS ARE
THE POWER COUPLE, RIGHT?
>> NICE. GOOD.
>> OKAY, HOW CAN WE GET, LIKE,
A LITTLE DYNAMIC INTERACTION?
LIKE, THE TWO OF YOU
MAYBE PULLING ON
THE BRIEFCASE TOGETHER?
>> LIKE, INTERACTING TOGETHER?
>> YEAH.
>> FROM SIDE-TO-SIDE MAYBE.
>> MAYBE BACK-TO-BACK EVEN.
YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH, THAT'D BE COOL.
>> IT'S KIND OF HARD
TO PICK THE POSES TO PORTRAY
THIS WEALTHY BUSINESSMAN
THAT EVERYBODY LOOKS UP TO.
>> WHERE--WHERE ARE YOU GOING
WITH THIS, DIONNE?
>> I JUST WENT BACK
TO, LIKE, THE MAGAZINES
WHERE YOU JUST SEE THE--THE MEN
IN THESE GREAT BUSINESS SUITS
NOT REALLY DOING TOO MUCH,
JUST KIND OF STANDING OFF.
>> I DON'T WANT YOU
TO LIMIT YOURSELF TO THINK THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO A LOT
IN THIS SHOOT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> 'CAUSE THERE'S A WHOLE LOT
YOU CAN DO.
DIONNE NEEDS TO LEARN
HOW TO STEP UP THE GAME
AND BECOME A TOP MODEL.
>> I AM THE ROCKER.
>> YOU OBVIOUSLY
WON THE CHALLENGE, RIGHT?
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO YOU'RE GONNA SHOOT
YOUR ALLOTTED NUMBER OF FRAMES.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND THEN COME TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FILM ON THE OTHER SIDE
TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO YOU REALLY HAVE
THE ADVANTAGE TODAY.
>> DEFINITELY.
>> I NEED YOU TO BREAK IT DOWN,
'CAUSE ALREADY YOU'RE GETTING,
POSE, POSE, POSE.
YOU'RE COCKING YOUR HIPS.
LOOK AT ME STRAIGHT
AND JUST RELAX.
SARAH, COME. LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> BECAUSE I WON THE CHALLENGE,
I GET TO GO
IN FRONT OF THE COMPUTER
AND SEE ALL OF MY 60 IMAGES.
>> SEE HOW POSE-Y THAT IS?
>> YEAH.
>> LOOK IT-- LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE
IN THE BODY LANGUAGE.
>> I SEE EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SARAH WAS VERY LUCKY
TO HAVE WON THAT CHALLENGE.
DIONNE PICKED EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT THE GIRLS WORE.
>> SO NOW YOU GOT...
>> (laughs)
>> ANOTHER 60 FRAMES TO SHOOT.
>> I WAS LIKE, I'M-A WIN
ONE OF THE DAMN CHALLENGES SOON.
I WAS LIKE,
THIS SHOULD'VE BEEN MINE.
>> DO YOU KNOW,
ALREADY YOU'RE MILES AHEAD
OF WHERE YOU WERE.
THIS EXERCISE MAY HAVE SAVED YOU
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> (laughs)
>> GOOD JOB. GOOD JOB.
>> HERE WE GO. NICE.
>> RENEE FEELS DIANA AND I--
WE'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH
TO BE IN "VOGUE,"
BUT THAT REALLY JUST
MOTIVATED ME
TO GET READY TO DO IT AGAIN.
>> I NEED TO GET MORE DYNAMIC.
PLANT YOUR FEET--
SOLID, MASCULINE, STRONG.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> YOU'RE STILL
IN THE ELEMENT OF CONTROL THERE.
IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T WANT
TO LET GO ALL THE WAY.
WHEN WHITNEY STEPS ON SET,
SHE OVERANALYZES.
WHITNEY'S GUARDED.
WHITNEY'S AWKWARD.
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL,
AND YOU GOT A GREAT BODY.
I JUST WISH I COULD
THROW SOMEBODY ELSE IN IT
TO USE IT.
>> GOT YOU.
>> NATASHA'S HIP-HOP.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
THAT'S SO FUNNY.
>> NATASHA IS BRINGING
HER "A" GAME.
THAT GIRL--SHE ACTUALLY
CAME UP TO ME AND ASKED ME,
"HOW DO I DO THIS?"
>> WHAT IT DO?
>> OH, OKAY.
WUDITDO, SHADA?
>> WUDITDO, SHADA?
>> (laughing)
>> (laughing) GOD!
>> AND SHE ACTUALLY PRACTICED IT
FROM THE TIME
WE'RE IN HAIR AND MAKEUP
TO THE TIME SHE GOT ON SET.
>> DID YOU SEE WHAT SHE DID
WITH THE FOIL ON HER TEETH?
>> (gasps) THANK YOU.
THAT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> OKAY, NATASHA.
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA SAY ANYTHING.
YOU SCARE ME.
♪♪♪
>> THAT'S GREAT. GOOD.
>> (all laughing)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> VERY COOL.
THERE YA GO. GOOD.
(laughter continues)
>> THERE IS A REASON
THOSE RUSSIAN PEOPLE COMPETE
AND GET GOLD.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THAT GIRL KNOWS HOW
TO IMPRESS PEOPLE.
GOOD.
>> AND IT'S GREAT WHEN YOU HAVE
ALL THIS POSITIVE ENERGY
WHEN PEOPLE LAUGH.
I ENJOY HAVING AN AUDIENCE.
I LOVE IT.
>> YAY!
>> (cheering)
>> NATASHA'S DEFINITELY
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT HAS BLOSSOMED
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> YOU WERE HILARIOUS TO WATCH.
>> I JUST LOVE BEING A MODEL.
MODELING GIVES YOU
POSSIBILITY OF BEING
ALL THESE DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
THAT YOU CANNOT BE IN YOUR LIFE.
APPRECIATE IT. WE'LL SEE YA.
>> SO YOU GUYS ARE
RED CARPET COUPLE.
>> HONESTLY, I DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS GONNA BE THAT DIFFICULT
TO POSE AS A GUY.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> DIANA, SHE IS OUTSHINING YOU.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU--YOU'RE JUST KIND OF
STANDING THERE LIKE THIS...
OKAY, LET'S GO...
>> HMM.
>> IT'S NOT INTERESTING.
>> I FEEL LIKE WHITNEY AND DIANA
FEEL PRESSURE
FROM LOOKING AROUND
AT THE OTHER GIRLS
WHO ARE THINNER,
AND THEY FEEL PRESSURE THAT
THEY HAVE TO REALLY STEP IT UP.
AND THEY'RE LETTING
THAT PRESSURE
ACTUALLY BRING THEM DOWN.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING,
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE BORED WITH IT.
THAT'S IT.
>> (sighs)
>> TELL ME AGAIN
WHY YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> JUST 'CAUSE.
>> "JUST 'CAUSE"?
IF YOU ASKED ME,
"WHY DO I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?"
AND I SAID, "WELL, JUST 'CAUSE,"
WOULD YOU WANNA HIRE ME?
>> NO.
YOU DON'T THINK I WANNA BE HERE?
>> NO, I THINK
YOU WANNA BE HERE.
I JUST WISH YOU KNEW WHY
YOU WANTED TO BE HERE,
AND I FEEL
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW WHY,
IT DOESN'T COME ACROSS
IN YOUR PICTURES.
YOU'VE GOT THE BODY FOR IT.
YOU GOT THE LOOKS FOR IT.
YOU NEED TO FIND THE PASSION
FOR IT.
>> OH, IT'S JUST
REALLY FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL HIM
TO MAKE HIM BELIEVE ME,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S HARD.
>> BECAUSE DON'T LET THEM
SEE YOU DOWN.
'CAUSE WE HAVE
SO MANY OBSTACLES TO OVERCOME
JUST BECAUSE WE ARE
THE FULL-FIGURED MODELS.
AND EVERYBODY WANTS
TO ILLEGITIMIZE US AND SAY
THAT WE'RE NOT REAL MODELS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH.
>> JUST GET YOURSELF TOGETHER,
FOR REAL.
>> I'M JUST REALLY DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF,
'CAUSE THIS COULD SEND ME HOME,
YOU KNOW?
AND I DON'T--
I'M NOT READY TO GO HOME.
(crying) GOD.
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY EIGHT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OH, GOD.
>> I DIDN'T PERFORM
TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITY
IN MY PHOTO SHOOT,
AND I'M VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT SEEING MY PHOTO.
RIGHT NOW I KIND OF THINK
THAT THE JUDGES REALLY LIKE
MY PERSONALITY.
HOPEFULLY, I CAN CONVEY TO THEM
THAT I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE THAT SUPERMODEL.
>> I AM A LITTLE WORRIED
ABOUT ELIMINATIONS.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT, YOU KNOW,
I NEED TO BE
STRONG AND CONFIDENT
IN FRONT OF THE PANEL.
BECAUSE IF THEY SEE ME WEAK
AND IF THEY SEE ME BREAK DOWN,
THEN THEY'RE GONNA THINK,
SHE'S NOT GONNA BE STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANDLE THIS.
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
>> HEY.
>> WELL, THERE ARE NINE OF YOU
IN FRONT OF ME.
UNFORTUNATELY,
ONE WILL GO HOME TONIGHT.
AMONG THE PRIZES ARE
A CONTRACT WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE, OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH...
AND TWIGGY,
FASHION ICON AND LIVING LEGEND.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU'VE COME TO KNOW THIS WOMAN--
CATHY GOULD.
SHE'S THE DIRECTOR
OF ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT.
>> GOOD EVENING, LADIES.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE.
DIONNE, YOU ARE FIRST, DARLING.
>> (laughs)
>> SO DO I NOT SEE A MODEL
FROM HEAD TO TOE STANDING
IN FRONT OF US THIS WEEK?
>> YOU DO SEE A MODEL
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
>> WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
>> FROM LAST WEEK TO THIS WEEK,
IT'S TWO TOTALLY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
LAST WEEK WAS A GIRL
THAT WANTED TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND WAS KIND OF STANDING IN LINE
AT THE MALL...
TO A GIRL NOW THAT LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S BEEN IN THIS COMPETITION
FOR FIVE WEEKS.
WELL, THIS WEEK
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
ALL OF OUR GIRLS
WERE TRANSFORMED INTO MEN.
AND THEN WE HAD MEN ON THE SET,
AND THE MEN
WERE TRANSFORMED INTO WOMEN.
>> (laughs)
>> YES, THEY WERE.
>> SO YOU HAD TO REPRESENT
A POWER COUPLE.
ALL RIGHT, DIONNE,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
(laughter)
>> THAT'S AMAZING!
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THIS IS SO WRONG, IT'S RIGHT.
>> (laughs) OH!
>> YOU'RE A NEW PERSON, DIONNE.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF
THIS IS YOUR FIRST WEEK
ON THIS COMPETITION.
>> I JUST LOVE HOW RELAXED
YOUR BODY IS, ACTUALLY.
>> YEAH, IT'S FABULOUS.
>> IT'S QUITE--
IT'S QUITE RELAXED.
>> I LEARNED THAT FROM YOU.
>> YOU LEARNED HOW TO BE A MAN
FROM MISS J.?
(laughter)
>> NO, HE TAUGHT--
NO, NO, HE TAUGHT...
>> OH.
>> AND THE DRAG QUEENS
LEARN HOW TO BE WOMEN FROM ME.
>> THERE YOU GO, GIRL.
>> WHOO!
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, DIONNE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> UP NEXT IS JASLENE.
JASLENE--ALWAYS GOTTA HAVE
AN ACCESSORY.
NOW YOU GOT A GUITAR
ON YOUR WAIST, GIRL.
>> (laughs)
>> OH, NO.
>> PLAY ME A SONG.
(humming guitar riff)
>> (laughs) IT DOES LOOK LIKE
A GUITAR.
THAT'S BETTER.
I THINK IT'S BETTER WITHOUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO, JASLENE,
YOU WERE A NAUTICAL COUPLE.
>> YES.
THEY BRUNG OUT THE BOY IN ME.
>> ALL RIGHT,
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
>> (laughs) MY GOODNESS.
>> WOW.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
>> I WAS LOOKING SO RUGGED.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A FELLA.
>> YOU DO. AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU LOOK LIKE
A GOOD-LOOKING GUY, TOO.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
THIS PICTURE, JASLENE,
IS THAT IT'S EFFORTLESS.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO ACT LIKE
A BOY.
IT'S JUST COMING FROM INSIDE.
IT'S LIKE IT'S A MAN
WALKING DOWN THE STREET
WITH HIS WOMAN LIKE,
"COME ON, BABY."
GOOD JOB.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UP NEXT--WHITNEY.
SO, WHITNEY,
YOU WERE PORTRAYING...
>> THE COLLEGIATE.
>> THE COLLEGIATE COUPLE.
>> MM-HMM.
OOH.
>> OOH!
>> YOUR CHEST SORT OF
GIVES YOU AWAY.
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT MORE BUTT
AND IT WOULD'VE WORKED.
THE WEIRD THING IS,
YOU LOOK SO MUCH LIKE A BOY
FROM THE HEAD
THAT I HAD TO LOOK TWICE
AT BOTH CHARACTERS
JUST TO WORK OUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> YOU LOOKED UNCOMFORTABLE,
THOUGH.
SOMETHING IN YOUR FACE
SAYS YOU'RE UNCOMFORTABLE.
WAS IT BECAUSE YOUR BREASTS
WERE SHOWING OR...
>> I WAS ACTUALLY TRYING
TO GO FOR, LIKE,
THE--THE REAL POMPOUS, LIKE,
PRESIDENT OF A FRAT,
FUTURE MILLIONAIRE-TYPE DEAL.
SO I JUST TRIED TO, YOU KNOW...
>> WELL, I HAVE TO SAY,
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE ONLY SHOTS WHERE
YOU'RE CLENCHING YOUR JAW.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND IT MADE YOU MASCULINE.
I FELT LIKE YOU WERE
DOUBTING YOURSELF,
A LITTLE CONFUSED BY THIS.
MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU WERE THE WORST OF THE DAY.
YOU NEED TO BE MORE CAREFREE
REGARDLESS OF THE CHARACTER
OR THE SHOOT.
YOU NEED TO LET GO.
YOU'RE TOO CONTRIVED.
AND IT'S INTERESTING THAT
I-I DO FEEL LIKE
YOU LUCK INTO YOUR SHOTS,
BUT IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN
BY ACCIDENT.
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING BY NOW
THAT YOU HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, WHITNEY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS JAEL.
>> HI, TYRA.
>> HI, JAEL.
WHAT KIND OF COUPLE WERE YOU?
>> WE WERE, LIKE,
A BOHEMIAN HIPPIE COUPLE.
>> THAT'S ALMOST
LIKE TYPECASTING FOR YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> (all laughing)
>> YEAH, I THINK THE PROBLEM
WITH THIS, JAEL, IS IF YOU
TOOK YOUR MUSTACHE AWAY
IN THIS SHOT,
YOU'D ACTUALLY BOTH LOOK LIKE
TWO GIRLS IN THIS PICTURE.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST PICTURE
THAT I'VE ACTUALLY--
MY EYES GO TO...
>> TO THE GIRL.
>> TOWARD THE GIRL, NOT THE GUY.
>> YEAH, AND I THINK
JUST THE WAY THAT SHE'S
HOLDING THE GLASSES
AND LEG POSE...
IT JUST DOESN'T CONVINCE ME.
>> SEE THAT LEG, HOW IT'S OUT?
YOU WERE KICKING YOUR LEG OUT
AND POPPING THE HIP A LOT.
IT WAS LIKE YOU COULD NOT
BREAK YOUR FEMININITY,
WHICH I FOUND... SHOCKING.
VERY RARELY DO I SAY "NEVER,"
BUT THERE WAS NOT ONE SHOT
WHERE IT WAS LIKE, WHOO,
THAT'S A MAN'S BODY LANGUAGE.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, JAEL.
UP NEXT IS SARAH.
>> HELLO. (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT, SARAH,
LITTLE PETER PAN.
WHAT KIND OF COUPLE WERE YOU?
>> I WAS THE ROCKER
WITH THE MODEL GIRLFRIEND.
>> YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER
THIS WEEK,
AND YOUR WIN WAS THAT YOU GOT
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF FRAMES
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
YOU WERE ABLE
TO LOOK AT YOUR FILM,
ANALYZE YOURSELF, THEN GO BACK
AND TRY TO IMPROVE THAT
WITH MORE SHOTS.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I LOVE THAT. I LOVE SOME...
>> I THINK IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
A GIRL--THE BODY LANGUAGE,
EVERYTHING.
>> I WAS JUST GONNA SAY THAT.
>> YOU THINK IT LOOKS LIKE A
GIRL?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THE BODY LANGUAGE, THE HIP.
>> OH, NO.
>> I AGREE WITH TWIGGY.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD PICTURE.
I THINK IT'S COOL, IT'S SEXY.
>> IT'S NOT THAT IT'S NOT
BEAUTIFUL. IT'S JUST--FOR ME,
IT DOESN'T--IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> THE ONE THING
THAT HELPED ME SO MUCH IS,
WHEN I SAW ALL THE FRAMES
I'D BEEN POSING WAY TOO MUCH,
AND I REALLY TRIED
TO LET THAT GO AND JUST
KIND OF... (sighs) YOU KNOW?
>> THANK GOD
YOU WON THE CHALLENGE, SARAH.
>> THAT'S WHAT JAY SAID.
>> 'CAUSE YOU WOULD'VE HAD
A SHOT LIKE THIS... "I'M A MAN."
>> MM-HMM. YES.
>> OKAY, THANKS, SARAH.
>> THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH.
>> RENEE.
OKAY, RENEE,
SO YOU WERE A WHAT COUPLE?
>> I WAS GLAM ROCK.
>> GLAM ROCK.
>> MM-HMM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> OKAY, GLAM ROCK.
THE GLAM ROCK--IT'S A BIT SOFT,
A BIT FEMININE...
>> DAVID BOWIE?
>> ANDROGYNOUS.
>> YEAH. YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M SORRY.
I LIKE THIS KIND OF LOOK.
>> YEAH, IT WORKS.
>> I THINK IT WORKS.
YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU'RE GIRLS.
THIS IS SORT OF
THE LINDA EVANGELISTA
KIND OF THING. SHE NEVER REALLY
LOOKED LIKE A GUY.
>> THIS IS A VERY GOOD ANGLE
FOR YOUR FACE.
I THINK YOUR NOSE LOOKS AMAZING
AND YOUR JAWLINE DOES.
>> AND SHE EVEN HAS
AN ADAM'S APPLE.
>> I LIKE THE TIGHTNESS
IN YOUR MOUTH, RENEE.
MEN, I FEEL, YOU ALL
HOLD TENSION IN YOUR MOUTHS.
NIGEL, YOU'RE JUST ALWAYS TIGHT
UP IN THERE.
>> I KNOW.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE CLENCHED JAW
WITH MALE MODELING.
>> IT'S THE CLENCH.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, RENEE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS DIANA.
HELLO, DIANA.
>> HEY.
>> WHAT KIND OF COUPLE WERE YOU?
>> RED CARPET.
>> A RED CARPET COUPLE.
>> (laughs)
>> I LIKE IT.
>> YOU BOTH ARE WORKING THIS
SHOT.
>> BUT YOU LOOK LIKE
A MOBILE PHONE WITHOUT A SIGNAL.
>> 'CAUSE THE--THE FACE
IS SLIGHTLY DEAD...
>> YEAH.
>> WHICH IS SLIGHTLY WORRYING.
>> SLEEPING PILLS.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY FUNNY,
BUT YOU LOOK LIKE A MANNEQUIN.
>> YES.
>> IT DOESN'T LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S ANY LIFE IN YOU.
>> I THINK THE PROBLEM
THAT YOU HAVE IS THAT
YOU REST ON BEING PRETTY.
MR. JAY SAID YOU NEED
TO DISCOVER WHY YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL...
"WHEN I ASKED WHY SHE WAS HERE,
THE ANSWER WAS, 'JUST 'CAUSE.'"
>> TELL ME AGAIN
WHY YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> JUST 'CAUSE.
I'M SO MAD AT MYSELF
THAT I SAID IT LIKE THAT.
>> HE FEELS YOU LACK PASSION
IN MODELING,
HAVE LACKLUSTER PHOTOS,
HO-HUM PERFORMANCE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THE PASSION FOR FASHION,
AND JAY SAYS HE DOESN'T SEE THAT
IN YOUR EYES.
ALL RIGHT, DIANA, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BRITTANY.
ALL RIGHT, BRITTANY,
AND WHAT TYPE OF COUPLE
WERE YOU?
>> WE WERE THE OUTDOORSY COUPLE.
>> ALL RIGHT!
DID YOU COME UP WITH
A NAME FOR YOURSELF?
>> UM... BOB.
>> BOB. YES.
>> (laughs)
>> I CAN TELL YOU DIDN'T,
BUT YOU DID JUST NOW,
AND YOU THINK QUICK
ON YOUR FEET.
GOOD JOB. ALL RIGHT.
SO HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I LOVE THE BODY SHAPE.
I LOVE THE ARM ON THE KNEE.
IT'S JUST EXCELLENT.
>> EXACTLY.
I WAS GONNA SAY THE EXACT--
>> AND I LOVE THE WAY
YOUR HALF-LIDDED EYES LOOK.
BOB, YOUR GIRLFRIEND'S GOT
A VERY BIG HAND.
>> (laughter)
>> IT'S HUGE.
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY
ABOUT BIG HANDS...
>> (laughs)
>> BIG GLOVES. COME ON.
>> YES.
>> WELL DONE. THANKS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS NATASHA.
SO, NATASHA,
YOU WERE WHAT KIND OF COUPLE?
>> A HIP-HOP COUPLE.
>> OKAY.
>> ♪ YEAH ♪
>> (all laughing)
>> YES, I LOVE IT.
>> WELL, IT'S WONDERFUL.
YOU'VE GOT SUCH A WONDERFUL,
JOYOUS SPIRIT
AND SENSE OF HUMOR,
AND YOU BRING IT
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS,
WHICH I LOVE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO YOU'VE BEEN STUDYING
FASHION MAGAZINES?
>> YES.
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
THE STUDYING WORKS FOR YOU.
>> OH, WAIT A SECOND!
HOW COME YOUR HEAD
IS UPSIDE-DOWN AGAIN?
>> EVERY WEEK!
>> EVERY WEEK,
YOUR HEAD IS LIKE THIS...
>> MR. JAY SAID THAT YOU WERE
ONE OF HIS FAVES FOR THE DAY.
YOU ENTERTAINED THE ENTIRE ROOM.
YOU EVEN MADE YOUR OWN GRILLE
FOR THE SHOOT.
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT'D YOU MAKE IT WITH?
>> UM, FOIL FROM THE GUM.
>> OH, FOIL FROM GUM.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY MY THOUGHT.
I BROUGHT IT UP TO THEM.
>> YOU'RE THE ONLY PERSON I KNOW
WHO CAN ACTUALLY
REALLY BOAST ABOUT THEMSELVES
AND SOUND CHARMING
AT THE SAME TIME.
(laughter)
>> ALL RIGHT, UM, NATASHA,
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH GENTLEMAN IS GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHAT MAN-LADY IS GOING HOME.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA.
>> WHEN NATASHA WALKS IN HERE,
SHE JUST LIGHTS UP
THIS WHOLE ARENA FOR ME.
SHE'S POSITIVE.
I LOVE HER TO BITS.
>> NATASHA LOOKS GREAT
IN THIS PICTURE.
SHE'S REALLY IMPROVING.
BUT SHE IS THE WEIRDEST GIRL.
>> I HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU.
>> AND NATASHA TAKES CRITICISM
AS A POSITIVE.
>> YOU CAN TELL HER,
"NATASHA, THAT IS
THE WORST PHOTO I'VE EVER SEEN."
(imitates Natasha) "THANK YOU!
I WILL TRY TO BE WORSER
NEXT WEEK!"
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH.
>> JASLENE.
>> WHAT A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH.
>> SHE IS
THE MOST PHOTOGENIC GIRL HERE.
>> DIONNE.
>> WELL, WHAT A CHANGE
WE SAW IN DIONNE TODAY.
SHE REALLY TOOK ON BOARD
EVERYTHING YOU TOLD HER
LAST WEEK.
>> DIDN'T SHE LOOK LIKE A MODEL?
>> SHE LOOKED LIKE A MODEL.
>> DIONNE IS A SPONGE,
AND SHE'S LISTENING,
AND SHE'S TRUSTING
THAT WE DO KNOW BEST.
>> SURE.
SHE'S THE MOST IMPROVED.
>> BRITTANY.
>> I JUST LOVE BRITTANY.
YOU KNOW, MALE OR FEMALE,
I LOVE BRITTANY.
>> SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT AS YOU KNOW,
BEAUTIFUL ISN'T THE ONLY THING
TO MAKE IT IN MODELING,
AND THAT WAS MY MAJOR CONCERN
WITH HER.
BUT I THINK, UH, SHE'S SHOWING
THAT SHE'S IMPROVING
AND SHE COULD BE A MODEL.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> RENEE.
>> WELL, AS YOU KNOW,
I THINK RENEE IS FANTASTIC.
I LOVE THE WAY SHE STANDS.
I LOVE HER WIDE SHOULDERS.
TO ME, SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> SARAH.
>> YOU KNOW, I-I LIKE SARAH.
I THINK SHE'S GOT
MODEL POTENTIAL,
BUT I WASN'T REALLY CONVINCED,
UM, IN THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
I DIDN'T THINK SHE GOT IT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> "DIAN-ER."
YOU KNOW HOW YOU PUT A "ER"
ON THE END OF STUFF?
>> (chuckles)
>> DIAN-ER.
>> (laughs)
>> SHE'S A GREAT-LOOKING GIRL.
SHE'S GOT INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL.
SHE'S GOT THE MAKINGS
OF--OF A GOOD MODEL.
SHE'S GOT A PERFECT
FULL-SIZE FIGURE.
SHE'S GOT THE HIPS.
SHE'S GOT THE BUST.
SHE'S GOT THE LOOKS.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANY OOMPH.
THERE'S NO FIRE.
>> DIAN-ER IS BORING
AND SHE'S BLAND,
AND SHE JUST DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIND,
I DON'T THINK.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> WHITNEY.
>> SUCH A SWEET GIRL BUT, YOU
KNOW,
TO ME, SHE'S NOT A MODEL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M SORRY,
I DON'T THINK WHITNEY'S
DELIVERING GREAT PICTURES.
SHE'S A BUSTY GIRL.
SHE'S GOT THE FIGURE.
IT'S HARD FOR HER TO HIDE IT
AND TO BE A MAN.
>> SHE CAN'T HELP HER BREASTS.
GIVE HER A BREAK.
>> (laughs)
(camera shutter snaps)
>> JAEL.
>> ALTHOUGH THIS IS
THE WORST PICTURE OF THE BUNCH,
I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT JAEL IS IMPROVING.
>> I KNOW, I... (laughs)
I'M SORRY.
I MEAN, IF SHE CAME IN
FOR AN OPEN CALL,
I'D JUST SAY "NEXT."
♪♪♪
>> NINE GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE EIGHT PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE EIGHT PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG WOMEN THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NATASHA.
WORK IT.
YO, YOU KNOW
THIS PICTURE'S DOPE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
LIKE, YOU NEED TO KEEP UP
THE GOOD WORK.
(laughs)
STOCKBROKER DIONNE.
>> AW, YEAH!
>> A REAL MODEL
STANDS BEFORE ME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BRITTANY.
CONGRATULATIONS, BOB.
>> (laughs) THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
JASLENE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA.
>> SARAH.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU BETTER THANK
THOSE EXTRA SHOTS THAT YOU GOT.
>> MM.
>> 'CAUSE YOU MIGHT NOT BE
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME
RIGHT HERE.
THEY REALLY WORKED.
IT JUST GOES TO SHOW,
WINNING THOSE CHALLENGES
DOES MEAN SOMETHING.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> RENEE.
COOL PICTURE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> JAEL.
SO YOU GOT SOME WORK TO DO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL WHITNEY AND DIANA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> TWO GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK HER BELONGINGS AND GO HOME.
I HAVE WANTED TO HAVE
TWO FULL-FIGURED MODELS
A PART OF THIS COMPETITION
FOR CYCLES AND CYCLES,
AND WE FOUND
TWO VERY, VERY STRONG GIRLS,
AND MY DREAM CAME TRUE.
OF COURSE,
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE WINNER.
AND IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING
TO ME BECAUSE I SEE
SUCH POTENTIAL IN BOTH OF YOU.
BOTH OF YOU ARE STUNNING,
STATUESQUE, BEAUTIFUL WOMEN.
DIANA, YOU ARE SO STRONG,
SO BEAUTIFUL.
BUT FOR SOME REASON,
THE JUDGES DON'T FEEL
THAT FIRE AND THAT PASSION.
WHITNEY, WE LOOK AT YOU
AND SEE A WOMAN
THAT LOVES HERSELF,
KNOWS SHE IS FINE.
BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO CAPTURE IT
IN A PHOTO.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
>> WHITNEY.
>> (crying) I LOVE YOU.
I'M SERIOUS.
(whispers) I LOVE YOU.
>> (mouths words)
>> YOU ARE
SUCH AN AMAZING REPRESENTATION--
AN IVY LEAGUE, BEAUTIFUL,
STRONG, FULL-FIGURED WOMAN.
SHOW US KEEPING YOU HERE
THIS WEEK
WAS THE RIGHT DECISION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
DIANA.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH...
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
I THINK YOU NEED
TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND EMBRACE IT
AND DON'T DOUBT YOURSELF
AND KNOW THAT
YOU ARE SO AMAZING
JUST THE WAY THAT YOU ARE.
OKAY?
>> YOU'LL SEE ME AGAIN.
>> OKAY.
I DON'T WANT THIS
TO BE THE LAST, OKAY?
>> IT'S NOT GONNA BE.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> SAY BYE TO THE GIRLS.
>> OH!
YOU'RE MY WOMAN.
♪♪♪
>> I'M GONNA MISS WHITNEY
PRETTY MUCH THE MOST.
(crying) YOU KNOW,
IT WAS VERY HARD TO BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO WITH HER
BECAUSE WE--YOU KNOW, WE WERE
THE CLOSEST IN THE HOUSE,
AND...
(exhales deeply)
I'M JUST GLAD, YOU KNOW,
THAT SHE CAN STAY,
AND, YOU KNOW, SHE CAN REPRESENT
FOR THE BOTH OF US.
OOH, BUT THIS IS A COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THEM'S GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND UNFORTUNATELY,
IT'S NOT GONNA BE ME.
(sniffles)
BUT YOU WILL SEE ME AGAIN.
(chuckles) YOU WILL.
I'M GONNA KEEP GOING.
AND THE GIRL THAT WINS--
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS HIT
A SMART AND SEXY PARTY
WITH NICOLE RICHIE
AND PARIS HILTON,
WHILE MAKING A SPLASH
WITH 50 CENT.
>> YOU AIN'T EVEN
SUPPOSED TO BE OVER HERE.
I ASKED YOU TO LEAVE.
>> BUT YOUR EYES WAS CALLING.
>> AAH! AAH!
>> AND JAEL PUTS RENEE
IN HER PLACE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DISRESPECTFUL
TO US, AND YOU'VE BEEN--
>> AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DISRESPECTFUL TO ME.
>> WITH GOOD REASON.